j'ai eu un volant
alors c'était des intestins de vaches il
y avait des tripes des coucougnettes
c'est très bon c'est fort c'est une
spécialité de la ville branlette
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
où est le respect on va on va
s'approcher les gens on dise que leur
bouffe est dégueu en plus non mais non
mais ça
les intestins
[Musique]
pas je mange pas
mal on mange des tripes
vraiment entre eux c'est entre la peste
et le colère en fait non mais c'est vrai
que je comprends que ça puisse se plaire
des programmes comme ça mais
personnellement en étant tout à fait
sincère je n'ai jamais regardé plus plus
de 10 minutes d'un des deux programmes
en fait donc c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas vers ça que je vais aller à la
rigueur je préfère le côté plage donc je
vais choisir quoi
je suis désolé pour l'intervention
maintenant
elle est très bien elle est honnête
Pékin Express et Koh-Lanta c'est des
problèmes qui ont quoi qui ont quasiment
20 ans donc c'est déjà pas mal qu'il
soit encore là
encore correctement même si c'est un
petit peu moins fort qu'avant
honnêtement ils vont pas le changer
maintenant ils vont pas avoir mal ou pas
l'arrêter hein pas tout de suite est-ce
que je peux poucave alors pour qu'il y
avait voilà je vais parce que avant
l'émission
Delphine
m'intéresse bien le maquillage j'ai
envie mais qu'est-ce que tu me donnes
du chantage dans cette émission bah
allez-y
[Applaudissements]
à chaque fois sur les le vendredi le 6 à
7 ouvert à tous tu sois tout le temps
de programme et la seule momenté qui
produit chacun des programmes pour
savoir en fonction de son avenir
son intérêt à dire l'un ou l'autre
je vais donc traduire comme le
producteur de Koh-Lanta et le même Fort
Boyard Fort Boyard emploie Delphine
bises auquel producteur est le même que
TPMP
elle s'est dit qui t'a autant autant
aller du bon côté ah voilà non
j'ai adoré Koh-Lanta j'ai adoré
Koh-Lanta il y a quelques années je
trouve que les deux formats je trouve je
suis pas d'accord avec moi Jean-Michel
parce que je trouve que quelqu'un est
prêt c'est vraiment on voyage Espagne
des choses le casting est plus
diversifié on n'est pas je trouve que le
format de Koh-Lanta sur une île déserte
je trouve que c'est vue est revu de plus
en plus je trouve qu'on s'amuse de moins
en moins c'est toujours la même chose
l'épreuve du radeau Denis Bretagne
je trouve que Koh-Lanta finalement ils
sont sur leurs acquis Express
c'est son choix j'ai envie de respecter
les tout le monde bien sûr